thank you thank you Kobe uh thank you
everyone so I'm glad to be back
so this uh this program and uh this will
be the second iteration of our course on
uh geometric deep learning
um that we already taught
in the air where my last year so as last
year this will be taught by myself with
my colleagues John Bruno from NYU Taco
coin from Qualcomm and better Village
coach from deepmind
uh you will hear from them uh in other
lectures as well so I will start with
the introduction
that uh I call maybe a little bit
arrogantly the airline program of
machine learning so we'll hear what uh
l18 program is and how it all started
maybe many years ago
and the gist of the course is the
fundamental principles that underly deep
representation learning and most of
modern deep and neurological detections
and if I were to summarize it in just
one single word this word is symmetry
and uh symmetry as defined by Hermann
vile
was one of the greatest mathematicians
of the 20th century he called it the
Symmetry slider is narrow as you may
Define its meaning is one idea by which
meant for the ages has tried to
comprehend and create order nuclear
imperfections and it really highlights
the important place that signature plays
not only in mathematics but also in in
physics as we'll see but also in the
parts in other fields of Science and it
occupied a special place for the ages
from surrounding and semantic designs so
pythagoreans who believed the circle to
be perfect due to its rotational
symmetry and in terms of the historical
overview that I would like to give in
this lecture it takes us back in time
where as Newton said we stand on the
shoulders of the Giants
so uh in this first lecture uh it will
be about how the notion of symmetry for
the ages has influenced geometry math
and eventually deep learning which is
the main topic of our course and
allowing us to reach the the point uh
where we are currently
so the term itself uh has Greek origin
symante and literally translates the
same measure and ancient Greeks use this
term to somehow vaguely convey the
beauty of proportion in art and Harmony
and music and Plato for example
considered the the five regular
polyhepra what we nowadays call the
protonic solids so fundamental that they
must be some kind of the basic building
blocks of the material world and it was
actually not very far from trolls and
Israel it was shown by the German
astronomer mathematician Johannes Kepler
he was actually the first to attempt the
rigorous analysis of the symmetric shape
of Water Crystals and wrote a book on
this called um on the the six cornered
sulfate which was actually a Christmas
gift to his friend in 1611 so he tried
to attribute the six-fold behavioral
signatory of snowflakes so uh what is
nowadays called hexagonal packing of
particles so if you take balls and you
try to pack them you will see certain
symmetric Partners emerge and this idea
though it preceded the clear
understanding of how matter is formed so
people have no idea about molecules and
atoms and Crystal lattices it still
calls today as the basis of modern
crystallography
now if we already mentioned in ancient
Greece uh modern geometry also Trace
traces back to ancient Greece and
probably the most seminal work there is
the work of Euclid the elements and what
we nowaday is called euclidean geometry
was in fact the only geometry that was
known for over 2000 years
and um the core of people India geometry
was a set of five basic assumptions
called postulates that were used to
providing a construction of theorems and
results in nuclear and geometry and it
happened that for hundreds of years the
fifth postulate about parallels stating
that it is possible to pass only one
line that is parallel to a given line
through a point that lies outside of it
it defied any attempt to prove it and in
fact many illustrous mathematicians
broke there is prime total to deal with
this uh postulate of parallels and for
example one early approach to the
problem appeared in 11th century it was
a work in Persian called the commentary
on the difficulties concerning the
postulates of Euclid's Elements by uh no
no else but Omar hayam himself I think
nowadays he's mainly remembered as a
poet and uh also hope the the wine the
flask of why the book of First and film
beside me but he was also a
mathematician and he studied the fifth
apostolate uh and apparently was
troubled by his inability to prove it
so this uh work was uh uh also
considered by uh Italian Jesuit living
in the 18th century called Joanna sakere
he was likely aware of qayam's figure's
work and his own work was called uh
Oakland is
Euclid cleared of everything literally
or of every fault so he tried to to give
back you clean the glory of every doubt
that was raised about uh about if it's
postulated
she considered an equivalent state with
about parallel lines considering the
summit angles of a quadrilateral that
now Bears his name where the size of the
perpendicular to the base and uh there
are three cases for the top angles to be
that are acute or right or uh or obtuse
and he concluded that in the case of
acute angles that leads to infinitely
many non-intersecting lines that can be
passed through a point outside of it uh
so counter it took intuitive that he
rejected it as Republican to the nature
of straight lines so he almost
constructed hyperbolic geometry and in
fact this work was rediscovered in the
19th century by Eugenio Beltrami one it
was already understood that this
construction was not crazy and nothing
back into anything it was a related
probably the almost first all was
successful such Construction
Monopoly came to an end in the 19th
century there was a remarkable burst of
creativity geometry was probably some of
the most exciting fields of mathematics
and probably
first was the development of projective
geometry so the enabler is associated
with it is
he was a French officer he participated
in Napoleonic campaign unsuccessfully in
Russia got imprisoned and spent his time
prolifically in in Russian prison
uh during these years he wrote a very
comprehensive three dies on projective
geometry and projective geometry it's a
special type of geometry where points
and y's are interchangeable and there is
no such thing as parallelism any two
lines intersect at exactly two points
and it's uh often not consider and
non-euclidean geometry particularly
speaking but it was probably the first
one to undermine the euclidean concept
of parallelism and I should say that it
was probably the uh reverse of
projective geometry because obviously
it's been uh it's been known since the
Middle Ages and even since Antiquity and
and artists use it to draw uh
perspective
projections and even there was a work of
his compatriot Gerard also a Frenchman
in the 17th century
apparently uh was one of the first to
get uh two uh ideas of proper and
non-nuclear geometry so actually the
credit for it is disputed
uh it is usually attributed
but Logan was the first to publish and
uh famously wrote to his father in 1823
that has discovered such wonderful
things that was amazed out of nothing
created a strange new a new world
and uh uh his uh his father he was also
a mathematician uh wrote about these
discoveries to Gauss he was probably the
the main mathematician of that period
which he was called the princess
the prince of mathematicians but Gauss
replied quiet Thursday he said that he
himself considered the same idea as 30
years before which was probably in the
beginning of the 19th century but he
never dared to publish them so he
considered this field to be immature so
as I said lobachevsky was the first to
publish so that was in 1829 and uh in
his work he considered the fifth auction
for the fifth postulate of uh Euclid an
arbitrary limitation as an alternative
he proposed a new one that more than one
mind can pass to a point that is
parallel of the given one and such a
construction as it was later explained
requires a special space that has
negative curvature what we now call have
harmonic space or hyperbolic geometry
and this idea was quite radical and I
would say heretical at the time of
publication and volvojevsky was openly
divided by colleagues whether
anonymously or people were putting their
name to attack something and yeah it was
not very popular and was not not
considered to be a good mathematics
so it goes in there to publish his ideas
about these new types of geology his PhD
student Bernard Raymond did and his
lecture on the hypothesis on which
geometry is based gave rise to what we
nowadays call differential geometry of
surfaces from Romanian geometry and he
also constructed as a particular case
non-neuclidean geometry of the sphere
that is sometimes called Romanian
geometry in the narrow sense and in this
case as well the fifth postulate of
Euclid doesn't called nor the second one
so all straight lines have finished
lengths and uh as you can as you know
you can take the globe that would be the
best example of uh this spherical
Olympic geometry
so as a result of these developments
what happened when we mentioned
essentially that there was an entire new
zone of different geometries so towards
the end of the 19th century they became
displace Fields with mathematicians uh
wondering uh which geometry is the right
one what actually defines in Geometry is
there any hierarchy right so there was a
fine projective elliptic euclided
hyperbolic geometry so it was quite a
messy situation
and uh it was in this uh interesting
moment that a young German mathematician
called Felix kleinstething so he was
just 23 years of age when he was
appointed in 1872 as a full professor at
the University of Ireland in Germany so
it was a small University in a small
town in barbaria
and as it was customer he was asked to
give an inaugural talk and write the
research
Prospect
to accompany it and this has entered the
history of automatics as the adelangan
program
and in this program Klein proposed
approaching geometry as the study of in
bryance or symmetries or the properties
that remain unchanged under some class
of Transformations and this approach was
a radical shift in the way that geometry
was constructed and understood and it
gave immediate quality by showing the
different geometries could be defined
by appropriately choosing the the the
the symmetries the class of
Transformations that you subject your
geometric shapes so for example symmetry
is defining the euclidean geometry are
rigid mode these are translations
Reflections and rotations and they
preserve angles distances areas parallel
lines and their intersections and if you
take a bigger symmetry groups such as
the fine group or projective code you
lose some of these properties but you
get more General geometries so for
client for example projective geometry
was the most
uh the most General one and the language
that client used to formalize the notion
of symmetry was the language of group
Theory it was also but at that time a
new field of mathematics it was born in
uh also in the 19th century so the first
time it was used was by verism
uh it was also French documentation that
uh died very young I think he was only
21 when she was killed in a duel and he
famously wrote down his results very
costly in a letter to a friend on the
night before his fatal duel
and group Theory nowadays is formally
associated with uh in addition to Galway
with client himself and with stockhost
Lee who work together and develop some
of the basic uh concepts of this
discipline
so uh historically maybe I should say
that though the airlines University is
obviously a very proud of its
association with Klein he didn't stay
there for long and eventually moved to
girdlingen which at that time was the
world's leading place for mathematics
it's the University where Gauss himself
had worked and the impact of the airline
program
uh on Geometry and Mathematics in
general was extremely profound not only
on mathematics I think it had a cultural
impact that's filled Way Beyond
and one field that was affected by these
ideas in particular was physics so uh a
person who worked with client in
government was Amy neuter
and uh she was a remarkable
mathematician and probably one of the
most influential figures in mathematical
physics of the 20th century and she
proved that every differential symmetry
of the action of a physical system has a
corresponding conservation law
and this is really fundamental and
stunning result because uh if you think
of conservation laws historically these
were mainly empirical observations so
you would have to do an experiment where
you uh measure someone property like
energy and you repeat this experiment
many times and you see that the energy
is concerned so you would grow this
conclusion so know if there's a theory
have shown that the conservation of
energy for example emerges from the
translational symmetry of time so it's
rather intuitive idea that if you make
the experiment today and tomorrow and
yesterday the result will uh will be
invariant it will be the same uh and
um
uh this was a really fundamental
understanding in physics and bile
himself had recorded in the beginning uh
use these ideas to develop the concept
of gauge environments as a principle
from which electromagnetism could be
derived and uh speculatively if he tried
to unify that this gravitational
interesting there is uh evidence of
Correspondence of him with Einstein that
the Target that this construction was
not physically correct
and with development of quantum
mechanics file the interpreted his
concept of gauge environments and it
took several decades until this idea in
some more generalized form that was
developed by Young and males in the 50s
became successful to provide finally a
unified framework that describes all the
fundamental forces of nature maybe with
exception of gravity for the time being
and this is what we nowadays call the
standard model in particle system and it
unifies the description of
electromagnetism weak interactions
strong interactions in the language of
cage environments expressed in group
theoretical language so this is more or
less all the physics that we currently
know
and I can only repeat the words of
another normal winning physicist Philip
Anderson that said that it's only
slightly overstating in the case to say
that physics is the study of symmetry
now at this point you may ask a question
what does it all all this excursion into
the history of geometry and physics uh
it might be interesting and exciting
what does it all have to do with deep
learning
and as we'll see next the geometric
Notions of symmetry and environments
have been recognized as first of all in
the in the very early days
of uh artificial intelligence and
pattern recognition and I think it's
fair to say that geometry has
accompanied this nascent field from its
very beginning
and um I think it would be an ingrateful
job total uh try to find a specific
point in time when the artificial
intelligence was born as a scientific
field I think humans have been I would
say obsessed with trying to understand
and comprehend intelligence
uh but what we'll try to do is uh maybe
a less risk and less in grateful task of
looking at the precursors of deep
learning I mean in particular we'll be
focusing on geometric ideas uh in this
field and this history can be packed
into less than the century
so uh probably
about a century ago it has become clear
that the Mind resides in the brain
and uh research efforts turn to try to
explain great functions such as memory
perception reasoning in terms of the the
structures of the brain methods and two
scientists Mark and beats are accredited
with the first mathematical obstruction
of the neuron the the fundamental brain
cell uh showing that it was capable to
compute logical functions
and what happened in the 50s in 1956
the legendary Dartmouth College Workshop
was convened where the very term
artificial intelligence was coined it
was the initiative mainly of John
McCarthy he would become a future curing
Laureate and the premise was that every
aspect of learning or any other feature
of intelligence can imprints for me so
precisely described that a machine can
be made to assimilate and maybe a little
bit arrogantly or wishful thinking they
thought that that meeting for a couple
of months over the summer they could
make important progress to solve these
problems and we are not even close to
some of these questions uh uh since uh
70 years
so uh just a year after in 1957 an
American psychologist Frank rosenblatt
that worked at the Cornell uh or an
article laboratory proposed a class of
artificial neural networks he called
precept funds that were supposed to
obstruct in some way the way human brain
works and learns and president pearls
were first implemented on a digital
machine learning dedicated hardware and
uh rosenbot showed that they managed to
solve simple pattern recognition
problems such as classification of
geometric shapes and he also proposed a
simple learning rule allowing to train
the president Trump to perform different
tasks and that that was quite uh
remarkable and uh it has led into a lot
of excitement not only in the field of
artificial intelligence but it was just
being born at that time but also outside
the field the the general broader public
a little bit similar to what we see
nowadays and maybe uh a little bit of a
hype so I can recall here at the
1958 New Yorker article that called
perceptrons a first serial a serious
rival to the human brain ever device so
I think this can make only a smile or
even worse the remarkable machines that
were capable of what the bounds to
thought
so if we hear about uh ideas or or
discussions whether neural networks are
conscious nothing is really new on the
Sun so these questions were asked 70
years ago
uh another example is there a somewhat
overconfident MIT summer Vision projects
that were was expecting a construction
of a significant part of a visual system
to achieve the ability to perform
pattern recognition in quotes like this
that was a new term it's not official
yet during one summer in 1966
and um a realization by the research
community that these initial hopes and
then this hype to solve intelligence
have been uh somewhat overly optimistic
was just a matter of time
and uh in 1969 uh this quick rise of
productionism so they work on artificial
neural networks how AI researchers uh uh
working on these neural networks label
themselves uh received somewhat uh
negative feedback that was devastating
in retrospective in the form of a book
called perceptrons by Marvin minskin
server paper from MIT
and um somehow in the Deep Learning
Community or in AI history research it
is common to retrospectively blame means
can papers for the onset of the first AI
winter which made neural networks fall
out of fashion four uh over the next
decades and the typical narrative
mentions the xor affair so it proved
that perceptrons were unable to learn
even very simple logical functions as a
result they have four expressive power
and basically good for nothing so I
should say that if you really read the
book
uh it is probably one of the
misunderstood and taken out of concept
works and indeed some of the statements
that are attributed so means game papers
were completely taken out of context
and some sources even at the beach of
drama to this AI Winter Story saying
that net Rosenberg and Minsky went to
the same school and even going as far as
saying that Frozen blood's premature
death he died in a sailing accident in
71 was not an accident it was a suicide
because he was devastated by the
criticism of his work but the reality as
it happens in most cases is probably
more nuanced and also more boring and uh
far more plausible reason for this AI
winter is what is called the Mansfield
amendment in 69 which acquired the
military to fund Mission oriented direct
research rather than basic and directed
research and it means that uh most of
the efforts in artificial intelligence
that were funded by the Army including
rosenbots research in particular uh
because they didn't show immediate
utility to the Army basically were cut
out of funding and as a result it had a
dramatic effect on the field
now if you look at the substance of the
the dispute and the accusations on both
sides what we need to understand is that
what rosenblad called the perceptron is
quite different from what mean skin
papers understood under this term and
they focus their analysis in their Book
on a narrower class of single layer
neural networks they call simple present
problems they're actually in the very
beginning they say they they use this
term in order of Frozen blood but it was
not exactly the same architecture that
rosenbot introduced
and uh basically these architecture is
what we nowadays called the process from
they computer weighted linear
combination of the inputs followed by a
non-linear function
uh Rosenberg have considered a broadcast
architecture uh with features that some
of which intubated the many ideas of
what would now be considered modern deep
learning including multi aware neural
networks with for example random and
local connectivity
and uh we mostly remember the book of
Minsky and papers for the role it played
in uh delivering this uh Devastation and
despair to the early day connection is
and and
uh some people even complain about the
Lost opportunities I think what is uh
importantly overlooked in this book book
is that it was probably for the first
time
a geometric approach and geometric
analysis of learning problems and this
fact is reflected uh in the very name of
the book that that as you can see it was
subtitled in tiny fonto and the
introduction to computational Geometry
so the full name was perceptrons and
introduction to computational geometry
and computational geometry at the time
was a radically new idea and one review
of the book that was from also from
Cornell and essentially stood
so the defense of Frozen blood uh wrote
that this new subject of computational
geology would grow into an active field
of mathematics or maybe it will pressure
out in the miscellaneous dead ends and
as we know today in retrospective
computational geometry is obviously a
very well established still so it did
grow into an active field of mathematics
but also meanscale papers probably
deserve the credit for the first
introduction of group Theory into into
the domain of machine learning and they
proved what they call the group
environment theorem saying stating that
if a neural network is environment to
some group then its output could be
expressed as functions of the orbits of
this group and we'll Define these terms
in the next lectures and they use this
result to prove the limitations of
perceptrons or what they consider simple
pressure problems
um but similar approaches were
subsequently used by
prominent researchers such as
shunichiyamadi
or Jonesborough Taylor or Karen zenovski
for constructing of environment features
in public recognition problems and some
of these early works that maybe are
almost forgotten nowadays real way the
the first foundations of what we'll call
the geometric deep learning blueprint
now uh again to the substance of this
dispute about the expressive power of
perceptrons rosenbot probably could have
rebutted some of these criticism uh had
he known about the pro of certain
Hilbert problem
so a certain scale but probably it was
one of the the famous silver problem uh
the the important outselling open uh
questions in mathematics the beginning
of the 20th century formulated by David
Hillman so the problem with
self-conceived whether uh the solutions
of
higher order polynomial equations can be
expressed by simple functions and it was
proven in a more General version
that established that a continuous
multivariate function can be written uh
as uh as I show here as a superposition
of continuous function of single
variable
and it was a precursor to a subsequent
class of results that were given the
name of universal approximation theorems
and um
uh specific versions for multi-layer
presses Thrones in the machine learning
literature
or derived by say benko according and
several other people afterwards already
in the 80s and the 90s and this is what
we typically call the universal
approximation property in machine
learning literature the ability to
approximate any continuous multivariate
function to any desire accuracy by a
multi-layer neural network
so in particular it was formulated for
multi-layer pressure problems unlike
simple single layer perceptron that was
criticized by mean scan papers if you
have a multi-layer network just two
layers from
these are Universal approximators so you
can take any function basically the idea
of the post is that you can take uh
these kind of pairs of uh of
layers in the presser Chrome and
represent step functions and once you
can represent step functions you can
decompose any function into steps of
arbitrary accuracy
now if you think of
supervised machine learning is a
function approximation problem where we
are given the outputs of some unknown
function let's say in case of image
classifier uh that would be something
that tells about the cats and those and
we are given a training set again inputs
of images and gets and dogs we try to
find a function from some hypothesis
class for example continuous functions
that fit well with training data and
allow us to predict the outputs on
inputs that we have never seen before
what's called generalization
and the universal approximation
guarantees that we can express functions
from a very broad regularity class in
this case continues by means of a multi
multi-layer neural network so in other
words there exists in neural network
with a certain number of neurons and
certain configuration of Weights that
approximate such function right uh
the mapping from the the space of cats
and dogs from space of languages to the
space of labels to any design that
perceived so in principle we can
represent this task
but this result doesn't tell us how to
suck in such a neural network it doesn't
tell us how to fight such ways and in
fact learning or finding the weights of
the neural network has been a big
challenge in the early days and what
Rosenbach showed as I mentioned was a
learning algorithm only for a single
layer from and now ubiquitous back
propagation became standard only in the
1980s
now if we look at the neural network
learning through the lens of
approximation Theory and some people uh
the column deprotting a glorified curve
fitting for this reason uh
the answer the question that we try to
answer is uh how many samples or
training examples do we need for uh
accurately approximate a task right like
image classification
and uh in approximation here we'll
immediately see that the class of
continuous functions that multiple
represent phones can represent is
obviously too large right we can pass
infinitely many such functions for a
finite set of points so there are even
examples of continuous nowhere
differentiable functions such as an
example constructed by bio stress which
have infinitely many jumps right so it's
a kind of fractal function that that is
jumps crazy there and so it's continuous
but has infinitely many casps so it's
all differentiable so it is uh necessary
to impose a digital regularity
assumptions such as lipids continuity
which is a kind of stronger notion of
continuity
and in this case we can provide a bound
on the required number of symptoms and
what happens is that these bounds do not
scale well with Dimensions or even these
nice and and friendly glass of lips
functions that the approximation here is
like uh when you can think of a simple
example so here we have a collection of
gaussian drops that are both in the
pattern of unit Square once we start
growing the dimension so the square will
become a hypercube we see that the
number of uh samples that we need to
take will grow with the dimension
exponentially and this is a class of
geometric phenomena that are Cooperative
known as the curse of dimensionality and
the curse of dimensionality in practice
in machine learning means that that in
even small scale pattern recognition
problems such as image classification
because they deal with input spaces of
thousands of dimensions
uh if one had to rely on just on
classical results from approximation
Theory machine learning would be
impossible and in our organization of
cat and dog classification the number of
images that will need to show to the
neural network will probably be more
than the number of particles in the
universe it will be humongously large
and simply there are not that many cats
and dogs around to be able to train on
so we need we need something else
and the struggle of machine learning
methods to scale to high Dimensions was
also prototyped by by the British
relative Edition uh Sir James lightfield
in a paper that AI historians call the
light Hill report
and uh in this report he used the term
combinatorial explosion and claimed that
existing AI methods could only work on
toy problems and would become
intractable in real world applications
that require higher dimensions and he
was very unhappy with the state of AI at
that time in the 70s and well in this
Photograph I think he also looks quite
unhappy and this report was commissioned
by the British research Council to
evaluate Academic Program research
in the field of artificial intelligence
and these pessimistic conclusions
resulted also in uh funding cuts and
together with several decisions in the
US that was a kind of a wrecking ball
or AI in the 70s so that was really the
the real motivation for the first uh AI
winter
now for us I think we will actually want
to take an optimistic conclusion from
this and this realization that classical
results like functional analysis
they cannot really provide an adequate
framework to deal with learning problems
and these will be the motivation to seek
stronger geometric forms of regularity
that we can Implement in a particular
configuration or wiring of the neural
network such as local connectivity of
convolutional neural networks and I
think it's fair to say that that
triumphant reimburses of deep learning
that that we we have witnessed uh a
decade ago is at least in part uh
attributable to these insights
and uh the inspiration for this uh first
uh new type of geometric architectures
uh came from neurosites
and it was a famous series of
experiments that were conducted by uh to
uh neurophysiologists working at Harvard
the David Hubble intern diesel in the
50s and the 60s that would bring them
the Nobel Prize in medicine afterwards
in the 80s
uh and these experiments studied the
structure and function of a part of the
brain that is responsible for partner
recognition what is called the visual
Aquatics
and uh the experience for conducted as
shown in this in this figure they
presented changing light patterns to a
cat and measured the response of its uh
of its urls
and by doing it it's very meticulously
they shown that the neurons in the
visual cortex have a multi-layer
structure with local spatial
conductivity and a cell would produce
response only cells in its proximity
what they call receptive Fields were
activated
not only that the organization appear
appeared to be hierarchical and the
responses of uh what they call Simple
cells reacting to local primitive like
oriented stuff like stimulus were
aggregated by complex cells which
produced responses to more complicated
patterns and it was hypothesized that
cells in deeper layers of the visual
cortex respond to increasingly more
complex patterns that are somehow
composed simpler ones and it was uh
initially semi-jobing they suggested
that there would be a grandmother neuron
that would react only when you are shown
in the face of your grandmother that
would be silent in any other situations
and actually I think in conventional
neural networks something similar has
been has been shown a few years ago
and this understanding or this first uh
insights about the structure and the
organization of the visual cortex
um has really had a dramatic and
profound impact on early Works in
computer vision and pattern recognition
and uh one such
results was the work of kudihiko
fukushiba in the 80s at that time he was
a researcher at the Japan Broadcasting
Corporation
where he developed a new neural network
architecture that was similar to the
model proposed by football and Diesel
that he called the Nail cognitron so
neocognito often is found as new or
cognitron but the name suggests that it
was a new version of cognitron which was
the name of a previous architecture that
focusing was suggested before that
consisted of uh what he called snc
layers of neurons so it's naming
convention obviously uh deferreds to the
covalent weasel the simple and and
complex cells uh they uh each such uh
layers were arranged in uh
two-dimensional uh arrays that followed
the structure of the input image with
multiple cell planes nowadays we call
these feature Maps uh per layer as you
can see in this figure and the S layers
were designed to be translationally
symmetric they aggregated inputs from a
local receptive field using shared
learnable weights and resulted in cells
in a single cell plane to have receptive
fields of the same function but in
different positions
and the regional wants to pick up
patterns that could appear anywhere in
the input whereas the C layers were
fixed and performed local pulling in the
form of weighted average
and these allowed insensivity to the
specific location of the pattern and as
a result the scene neuron would be
activated if any of the neurons in its
inputs are activated
and um
since the main application of the nail
polish Neutron was a character
recognition uh The crucial property was
a translation invariance and uh this
property was a really a fundamental
difference from earlier neural network
architectures such as rosenbots
perceptron
yeah and in order to use a pressure
problem reliably for example you would
have to first normalize the position of
the input pattern which was a difficult
task on its own whereas in your
cognitron the insensitivity to the
pattern position was kind of baked into
the architecture
achieved these translational uh
insensitivity by each reliving
translational equivalent local feature
extraction layers with spooning gate
will give formal definition to these
Notions
and this way it created a multi-scale
representation we'll call this a
principle of scale separation
and we'll also see why it can also help
to deal with broader class of geometric
Transformations not only pure
translations
and uh Fukushima also made some
computational experiments and he was
able to successfully recognize complex
patterns such as lectures or digits even
in the presence of noise and geometric
distortions so you can see this is a
figure from from his paper
and uh
we have the the advantage of looking at
retrospective
uh what 40 years since there has been a
lot of progress in the field and I I
think
it's remarkable that the nail
combination has uh a lot of
characteristics of modern deep learning
architectures so first of all it was the
and in the paper she simulated up to
seven layers that one uh it had local
receptive Fields shared weights and
pooling and even use the car rectifier
or value activated excavation function
which is somehow often believed to be
only recent introduction in the Deep
learning architectures
what really distinguished it from Modern
deep Learning Systems was the way the
network was trained so it was a kind of
what he called self-organized
architecture essentially unsupervised
plastering-like approach
because back propagation uh can still
not been widely used in the Urological
community
and learning of neural networks
uh as I said was challenging and for
many years there was no good way of
doing it so rosenbot
devised the learning role for a single
layer process from to train deeper
neural networks so there were other
approaches so uh
Ukrainian scientists in the 60s proposed
what he called the group method of data
handling nothing to do with group Theory
it was a way of dealing with polynomial
activation functions and it allowed him
uh in the early 70s trained deep neural
networks with uh up to eight layers so
that was quite remarkable if you think
that uh deep neural networks are
something in recent yeah so that was 15
years ago
uh the Breakthrough in the field came
with the invention of back propagation
so it's not written that gives us the
chain rule to compute the gradient of
the waves with respect to the loss
function and it allowed to use a
gradient descent based optimization
techniques to train neural networks
and as of today it's the standard
approach in deep learning
and the game as it happens with many
simple and important ideas
uh the roots of it can be traced back at
least of the 60s but I think it's fair
to say that the First full of basic
demonstration of this method in neural
networks was the paper of David Rudolph
in nature from 1986
and the introduction of this efficient
learning method was really the key
contributing factor to the return of the
neural networks to the artificial
intelligence seen in the 80s and the 90s
so talking about Fukushima and the nail
cognitron so this design was adopted and
further developed by none else but the
only come
then she was a fresh graduate from the
University of Paris with the PHD thes on
the user pack propagation for training
neural networks and uh in his first
postdoctoral job at the atnt labs he
built a system to recognize handwritten
digits that were written on envelopes
and this system was supposed to help the
U.S Postal Service to automatically
allow mail
and in his 89 paper they come described
the first few air convolutional neural
network actually the name convolutional
network was introduced only in a later
paper the the architecture in the 89
paper was no name
and uh it was quite similar in principle
to them of neutron he also used local
connectivity with shared weights and
pudding but it importantly for when
more complex non-linear filtering the
inhibitory Connections in fukushima's
architecture in favor of uh simple
linear filters that could be efficiently
implemented as convolutions using
multiply accumulate operations on the
digital signal processor or a DSP so
that was about the time
uh when this kind of Hardware
architectures emerged and this design
choice that departed from the
Neuroscience inspiration and also in
departed from Neuroscience terminology
so if you read uh fukushima's paper it
is written by uh foreign audience of
neuroscientists if you read the accounts
paper it's written for single processing
experts so it allows to move the entire
play to the domain of single processing
and that would be a really crucial for
the future success of deep learning so
basically it fell into the hands of HDs
and became essentially a single
processing job
foreign
this work essentially showed
convincingly first of all the power of
gradient-based methods for complex
pattern recognition tasks something that
that may be just indicate before would
be unimaginably difficult
it was also one of the first practical
deep learning based systems for computer
vision
and this Evolution release architecture
was evolved quite significantly so a CNN
with five layers that was in the net 5
was probably a part of the the name of
the first author uh in the 90s was used
by banks in the United States so
automatically recognized handwritten
chats
but uh in the computer vision research
community
somehow the vast majority uh was not
convinced by neural networks
for a variety of reasons and uh looked
uh into a different direction for
constructing very carefully designed
handcrafted feature detectors and these
pictures
and in the next decade this was the
mainstream of computer vision research
typical architecture for visual
recognition systems
uh was uh as I said a set of carefully
handcrafted feature extractors at these
pictures so typically you would detect
some interesting Salient points in an
image and then provide their local
description the way that is robust so
maybe mild prospective Transformations
and contrast changes so the famous
algorithm in that domain was sift the
scale Environ feature transformed by
David long and then these features would
be somehow aggregated so again famous
paper by C Vision
the the visual Google
uh introducing the bag of features
aggregation and then you would apply to
a simple classic typically support
Vector machine
and uh the balance of power however
changed by uh the rapid growth in
computing power
and the emergence of uh Graphics
Hardware the gpus that allowed to
perform
general purpose computation
and also the models of available
annotated visual data and it became
possible to implement and trade
increasingly bigger and more complex
conversational neural networks and
address increasingly more challenging
visual recognition tasks and the Holy
Grail at that time was uh in computer
vision the image that large scale visual
recognition challenge that that was
pioneered by Lee FeFe and it was an
annual challenge that consists a
consistency it still it runs but maybe
it's slightly modified version
basically the idea was to classify
millions of human labeled images into
about thousand different categories
and uh I seen an architecture that was
developed by uh Alex tejevsky and
cultures at the University of Toronto in
2012 managed to beat by a very large
margin all the competing approaches in
computer vision based on this
handcrafted descriptors and uh Alex
status the architecture was named in
order of its developer uh was a
convolution it was uh significantly
bigger in terms of the number of
parameters and layers compared to its uh
uh precursor the net five but
conceptually the same and probably the
main difference was the use of a GPU for
trading and again there were not the
first to do it but it was probably the
most convincing application of GPU EOS
for deep learning
and the success of CNN's on imagen
became really the turning point for deep
learning in computer vision and uh it
signaled its forward Acceptance in the
following decade and uh multi-billion
Industries emergence result with deep
learning successfully used in commercial
systems that nowadays range for speech
recognition such as ceiling or Apple
iPhone so self-driving
autopilot and desktop
and basically more than 50 years after
the review that killed rosenbots work
and a connectionists and neurologicals
were finally Vindicated and as you
probably know lecantine in the danger
received the curing award for their
lifetime work on deep learning there is
also an opinion that I personally share
that Jurgen Smith over was Injustice
excluded from the price but at this
point it's already history
so in the last bit before I conclude I
would like to briefly talk about graph
neural networks it will be a problem
Topic in this course and
um if the history of symmetry
as we've seen is tightly intertwined
with physics
in the history of graph neural networks
and graph theory is uh Inseparable from
another branch of natural science which
is chemistry
chemistry has historically been still is
one of the most stated in the Intensive
academic disciplines
and um the emergence of modern chemistry
in the 18th century when they
transitioned from medieval Alchemy
so a real science
resulted in the very rapid growth of uh
known chemical compounds and uh an early
need for their organization
and this role was initially played by
periodicals so the the German chemical
Central Blood that that's what is one of
the oldest journals started appearing in
in the beginning of the 19th century the
first chemical abstract Journal
or uh companion such as the the belstein
khanbo uh so uh where this is uh you can
see it here in this picture so that was
a collection of about 500 volumes with
half million pages
so it's just an indication of the share
amount of data that that quickly made it
impractical to print and use
for reference
so in the English speaking world the
chemical abstract service or cuss
was created in the beginning of the 20th
century in
1907 and it has gradually become the
central repository for the world's
published chemical information
and uh in the first half of the 20th
century this problem of organizing
searching and comparing molecules in
databases of chemical compounds became
of crucial importance uh both in
academic and commercial use of chemistry
for example when uh let's say
pharmaceutical company uh wanted to to
patent the new drug then the patent
office had to verify what a similar
component had been previously deposited
right so how do you know if you need to
compare molecular classes in a database
and to address these uh challenge
several systems for indexing molecules
were introduced in the 40s and this form
the foundation of a new discipline that
is now called chemo informatics and one
such system named uh gkd chemical Cipher
uh named after the author's Gordon
Kendall and Davidson in 1948
it was developed the the English style
for Dunlop and was supposed to be used
with early punch card based computers so
you see here an example of a punch card
where these kind of information will be
encoded and then presumably you can use
this kind of ciphers to better search
for molecules and in essence it was an
algorithm for parsing a molecular
structure into a string that could be
more easily looked up by human or an
early computer
but uh these these cyphers and similar
methods were very far from Satisfaction
and uh you need to understand that in
chemical compounds uh similar structures
are often those that result in similar
properties and can be sort of trained to
basically talk build an incubation to
spot such analogies
so uh you would look for example for
aromatic readings or certain chemical
groups and when the molecule is
represented as a string chemically
meaningful structures might be lost as
you can see in this figure you see that
that the molecules fracture on the right
is a a substructure of the molecule
called the left but it's string
representation is very different so you
don't have this local spatial coherence
that you see in the in the structure
itself and this realization uh has led
to the development of structural methods
for molecule search and one such famous
algorithm is the Morgan fingerprint
which is still used today maybe it's
slightly evolves form that was
introduced by Carrie Morgan from the
chemical abstract service in 1965. and I
should say that actually I tried to look
him up and from what they find uh
apparently Morgan uh didn't work much on
science he soon moved to a management
position at IBM from which he retired I
think in the 90s so that was one of his
few chemical papers
and then in this field uh a prominent
and probably unjustly forgotten figure a
pioneer of cable informatics is Romanian
chemists called George vados
so he trained as an organic chemist in
the Soviet Union and his interests in
chemo informatics was triggered also by
a traumatic encounter with this gigantic
Bell Stein handbook in his first year at
course on organic chemistry so he's
Professor apparently built a barricade
of this 500 book and said that they need
to
to to learn what is written there and
let us sort ways to compare molecular
structures represented as graphs and
using techniques in graph Theory which
was only developing at that time uh to
deal with molecules and you know that
this Choice should not be surprising
because graph theory has been
historically tied to chemistry even the
term graph in the sensor is used in
graph theory was first introduced by
James Sylvester in 1878 as a
mathematical obstruction of chemical
structure so the equivalent term to use
was chemical graph and that was his
paper in nature in that year
and uh Vlad was inspired two young
mathematicians uh Andrei lemon and Lori
Spicer uh who developed a classical
algorithm to determine whether two
graphs are structurally equivalent or
isomorphic
so basically two graphs have the same
productivity up to rewarding of the
nodes
and this is a card problem and I should
say that its complexity was not fully
understood at that time even the notion
of complexity itself was kind of fluid
notion in the 60s
uh level also considered himself a
programmer which was still an exotic
profession around that time and vice
president was an algebraic geometry and
uh they worked on the problem that uh
was opposed by dragons at least judging
by the acknowledgment in the 1968 paper
they proposed an alternative color
refinement scheme that they conjectured
to solve the graphics of office and
program
and it doesn't need so for small crafts
up to nine nodes that was confirmed by
Lemon computationally but if you go for
larger graphs you can see that uh there
are some counter examples
so uh for a lot of time actually the the
complexity of cafes overseas was uh
unknown and only recently uh last Obama
I showed that it can result in quasim
polynomial time it is usually put into a
separate complexity class
now this works uh from the 60s uh on
molecular representation probably the
main practically are known in the
machine learning community and that's
one of the reasons why it is really hard
to point or a particular point of time
when the concept of crafting or networks
was created
and in part it's due to the fact that uh
most of the early Works in machine
learning didn't really consider graphs
as kind of first-class citizens maybe
partially because graphql networks only
became practical in the late 2010s
basically nowadays and maybe also
partially because the field emerged from
Conference of several adjacent research
areas whether it's computational
geometry computer Graphics crafting or
processing and so on
so uh early forms of graph neural
networks uh probably go back to the 90s
examples such as labeling Ram by
Alessandro from 19 1994 or back
propagation Source structure by the two
Germans Gola and kukler from 96
so uh the first proper treatment of the
processing of generating graph structure
and also the first introduction of the
term graphql Networks happened already
in the 21st century the University of
Siena team that was led by Marco Gori
and Franco casselli that first proposed
the Glens that's currently known and in
this work they relied on the recurrent
mechanism so it was a kind of a way of
generalizing recurrent neurological
cross-structured data and require the
neural network parameters to be
configured in the way that they form
what is called contractive mappings
so it required a special form of
known representation that would produce
fixed point
and this required a special form of
backup propagation so it was a
conceptually important Milestone
probably not the best neural network
architecture some of these issues were
rectified by a work from 2015 the gate
and gnns by Elian Courthouse that
brought maybe benefits of modern
recurrent neural networks that already
used techniques for modern deep learning
such as gating mechanism and back
populations of time
and
maybe in some theoretical twist of fate
modern gnns were reintroduced I would
say triumphantly the chemistry I feel
that they were they originated from by
David duvino 2015 as a replacement for
the handcrafted Morgan molecular
fingerprints so this is really ironic
because device for a lemon algorithm
that was shown uh in 2018 by Sean Morris
to be equivalent to to graph your
networks to message passing graphql
networks was actually inspired and
originated from ideas and chemistry and
then probably one of the most known
Works in graphical networks by Justin
Gilmer from Google from 2017 the message
passing neural networks
uh were all finished just for chemical
applications
so again 50 years have passed and the
circle is finally closed
and the last thing I should mention that
uh the field of chemistry or maybe more
specifically structural biology the
study of proteins which are big
molecules
that's also have its own image that
moment and then a cast competition were
people try to predict that a 3D
structure of proteins and the newcomer
Alpha fold from leap mind person 2018
and then in 2020 smashed all the
competitors and it was also a geometric
architecture that heals uh some of the
Notions of a group in various as
equivirus that we'll be discussing in
this course uh as the foundation of the
architecture and we'll have a guest
lectured by one of the developers of
alpha folks 2 that will shed more light
on how this architecture works
so
our historical overview of the geometric
foundations of me pruning now naturally
brings us to a blueprint that will be
underpinning this course
and uh if we take convolutional and
graphical networks as two prototypical
examples which are the first ones may be
completely unrelated we still see
several common traits
and first both operate on data such as
images in the case of crns or molecules
let's say in the case of gnns that have
some underlying geometric domain so in
the case of images it's agreed in a case
of molecules it's a graph
uh secondly in both cases the tasks have
some natural notion of environments so
for example embrace the position of the
object in the case of image
classification or let's say the
numbering of atoms in a molecule when
you try to predict its chemical
properties such as solubility or binding
energy
and this can be formulated through
appropriate choices of symmetry group so
the translational group in the case of
the green and permutation group in the
case of a graph
uh
the third in both in cmns and gmns we
can incorporate
the the symmetries as an inductive bias
by making appropriate layers
like how the e-tracked with the action
of this Imaging or the input so in crns
for example
it comes in the form of convolutional
layers and the output of convolutionism
we'll see
transforms in the same way as input so
this is what we call translation
equivalence
which is the same as saying that
conversion commutes with the shift
operator
in the case of grns it comes in the form
of a symmetric message passing function
that Aggregates the naval nodes
irrespective of their order and the
overall Outlook of message passing
transforms in the same way as the
permutation of the input so for example
I uh if I sum the features of the
Neighbors in a graph then I don't care
about the order
of these features in destination
and the last in some architectural
instances of these networks in
particular in conventional neural
networks we have a multi-scale way of
posting the data so the pulling layers
that uniformly subsample the the grid
that underlies the image or in some
types of gmns it takes the form of graph
costly
now the term geometric deep learning so
we popularized it in the paper in uh by
Triple E single processing magazine is
kind of
uh
so
to hold uh intention to first of all
apply geometric principles to learning
in on the one hand and on the other hand
apply learning so data that doesn't have
green-like structures such as graphs or
meshes and uh the the extended paper
that we wrote with Joanne better and
taco that will become a book with MIT
press called geometric deep learning
really captures the ideas that I'm
trying to convey in this course
and maybe somewhat arrogantly we call
this the airline program of machine
learning and uh it's a way of trying to
reconcile the zoo of different
architectures that also emerge
historically for different types of data
developed from different considerations
whether cnns or gnns or rnns or
Transformers will see that these are
just instances of the same blueprint
so we'll be relying on uh group Theory
same way as client and his role in
program
uh to formalize our genetic deep
learning blueprint and we'll be modeling
the Symmetry structure of the domain by
Echo that I denote here by G it's a
representation will be acting on signals
living on the domain and that I will be
denote here by raw and then the
functions that will Define on these
signals will incorporate this property
in the form of environments or
equivalents
and uh as an example we'll see in
convolutional neural networks the choice
of translation Europe on the green uh
its representation is the shift operator
and an equivalent function is
convolution in case of graphql networks
that the underlying
uh symmetry group is permutation and the
functions take the form of message
passing I should say that uh the more
modern architectures that are used on
geometric graphs of particular in
chemistry in protein folding prediction
such as
the alcohol took there is also an extra
structure that is symmetry of the data
so if you're familiar with physical
Concepts you can make the difference
between internal and external symmetry
symmetry of the field and the symmetry
of the of the space-time
and release takes the form of uh
equivalent message passing or equivalent
Transformers are equivalent graphical
networks where we in addition have the
transformation or occupies with respect
to the for example spatial coordinates
of the atoms in the molecule
so this again is a particular instance
of this blueprint and together these
principles give us a very general
design that you can recognize in the
majority of popular deep neuroelectric
architectures so typically we apply a
sequence of equivalent layers that
preserve the structure of the domain
possibly followed by an in-barrant
global cooling layer that Aggregates
everything into a single output like an
image classification in some cases we
can also create hierarchical domains by
coursing procedure and this is the
pulling that is implemented in neural
networks
and uh it is implementation of another
very important physical principle that
is called scale separation and this is
really what allows physics to work right
so if you think of a thermodynamical
system so in the microscopic level we
can talk about the quadrilla of
molecules that Collide and move uh let's
say in this room but if I zoom out and I
look at how a thermodynamical system is
behaved I really need just a couple of
parameters such as temperature and
pressure to discuss to describe the
properties of gas in a very reasonable
way and if I further move out and look
at the cosmic scale for example the
Earth and all its complicated atmosphere
with different pressure and temperature
uh is completely irrelevant when I'm
talking about the motion of uh of the
planet around the sun right so in this
case there's going to really be
abstracted as a point
and uh geometric deep learning blueprint
that is based on these two principles of
symmetry and scale separation
uh can be applied to different types of
domains or geometric structures will
obviously seek out of python greens so
these are convolutional neural networks
more General homogeneous spaces such as
for example the sphere uh also graphs
and manifolds meshes uh geometric graphs
and so on
and um the implementation of these
principles basically gives rise to
inductive biases that leads out to some
of the most popular architectures that
exist nowadays in deep learning whether
it's cnns that come from translational
symmetry graph neural networks or deep
sets or Transformers they all stem from
permutation environments and intrinsic
cnns that are used in computer Graphics
in Vision that can be derived from BH
symmetry
so we'll talk about it uh during the
course
uh what is also cool about geometric
deep learning and in particular about
graph neural networks that have become
ubiquitous in a broad range of problems
and applications and really the ranges
goes from uh detecting misinformation
fake news
and they said for example a startup
company
that I co-founded with my students that
was acquired by three to three years ago
or improving uh navigation in Google
Maps so that was the work done in Google
deepmind in which data was involved
detecting uh events in particle
colliders or high energy physics is now
prominently using graphql networks in
different uh ways and for different
problems and some of them were already
being implemented in Hardware so we
might even see them at some point uh
put it in in the detectors
uh structure biology so I mentioned
Alpha phone so there is a lot of
interest in understanding how proteins
behave and interact
from the standpoint of geometry and
geometric machine learning as well as
drug Discovery and Drug design so we've
been quite
impressive progresses in this field in
the past few years including for example
the famous paper itself about the
discovery of new antibiotics using
grapheneal Networks
so to summarize I think if uh I started
with symmetry as a kind of big idea that
that encapsulates this course I would
like to finish with a code for milvezius
who said that the knowledge of
principles compensates for the lack of
knowledge of facts and this is the kind
of idea that I want to you know to have
in mind When approaching deep learning
so deep learning is often taught as a
collection of hacks so do this kind of
uh thing and do that kind of thing for
that particular problem with that
particular data we hope to convey a
broad set of principles based on which
you can understand first of all what
exists there so existing architectures
and hopefully also design future
architectures that are yet to be
invented
now let me say in the remaining time a
few words about the logistics of the
course
so uh there will be 12 lectures so after
this introduction you will hear from
Johann about the basics of ml in high
dimension so that will be some kind of
Common Ground I'm pretty sure that that
some of these things you have heard so
we'll hear about the curse of
dimensionality for example in a more
formal way
then Taco and John will be talking about
geometric priors we'll hear about
Symmetry and scale separation uh Petra
will be talking about learning on sets
and graphs so that will be mainly uh
towards graph neural networks will then
in the seventh lecture talk about grids
so that will be convolutional neural
networks the device from first
principles
uh then more General approach
generalizing this through homogeneous
domains such as the Seer we'll hear from
DACA I will talk about midi faults
meshes and geometric graphs then Taco
will talk about gauges and bundles uh
better we'll talk about using category
Theory as an extension to the erlangen
program so that's a new lecture actually
based on some results from this year
and uh finally I will
conclude with some applications and and
open questions and Trends so for most of
the course we'll be following our
protocol board so that was the long
paper that I mentioned that was
published last year you can find uh the
paper and some materials on this website
generating deep learning.com and here
are some reference to the
sections in this paper
and we'll also have uh several guest
lectures
from uh some of the prominent research
in the field researchers in the field so
we'll hear from Francesca and Giovanni
from Peter about gmns from physical
perspective so how to relate graphical
networks to differential equations
and how to derive them as gradient flows
of some energy
from from base of roster we'll hear
about subgraph gnns and please go dive
deeper into graft Theory and talk about
such constructions as the Reconstruction
conjecture we'll talk about expressive
power device for 11 tests
and uh and so on uh Chris Bodner from
Cambridge will talk about uh how to uh
lift craft neural networks so more
to richer structures called cellular
shifts relating uh gnns so to diffusion
equations on these exotic objects
then Jordy Williamson from University of
Sydney one of the key experts in
representation here will connect
geometrically product to this field and
finally a participates from deepmind one
of the authors of alpha phone 2 will
talk about uh geometric insights in
protein folding
so that's it